♫ Bring the tacos, bring the tacos
(humming)
- So excited!
Is it a taco, or is it pizza?
I don't know!
(man laughs)
(swish and creaking)
(cheerful music)
- I feel like tacos are great food
because you can just have so
many different kinds of tacos
and never get bored of it.
- Breakfast tacos, lunch tacos,
dinner tacos...
- There's too many
kinds of tacos.
- A deep, deep profund love for pizza.
- Pizza
- Pizza.
- is my favorite food.
- Breakfast, again.
Breakfast, lunch, dinner.
- Breakfast, lunch, dinner.
- Like, if I've had
weird dreams about tacos,
I've had naughty
dreams about pizza.
- (laughs) Oh my God!
Yes!
- Oh, F me up, Tony Baloney!
- (laughs) Oh my God!
- Ahh!
- I mean, it smells good.
We've got, everything's movin' right now.
- It's a heavy,
- I'm gonna try it.
- it's really,
- It's heavy?
- I can barely lift it, feel that.
That's like, a 10 pound pizza.
- Oh, ooo!
- It's a pizza shaped box,
so I guess I'm assuming
it's a taco flavored pizza?
- Oh!
- Wow!
(woman gasps)
- Are you
kidding me?
- Uh-oh,
woah!
- What?
- I wanna cry.
- It looks like
a bunch of vaginas.
(man laughs)
That was my first thought!
- Every single one of these is like,
a different flavor of taco.
- It's all here.
- It smells delicious!
- Yeah.
- It smells both of pizza and taco.
- The first thing we have to do is just
take a chunk of guacamole to the face.
- Is that?
- And I'm not upset about it.
- So the question is,
do you still fold it?
Like, your pizza?
- I don't know if
you can fold it.
- Also, is it a real pizza
underneath all these tacos?
- Oh!
That's a good question!
- Honestly, how do we
eat this fucking thing?
- They're beautiful!
- I don't think there's any rules
to how to eat this pizza
that breaks every rule.
- I'm gonna do an initial
bite, a side bite,
and then I'm gonna grab it with my hands.
- Cheers!
- L'chaim!
- I'm continuing to be lost in the sauce.
- Maybe you're supposed to
remove the tacos,
- Oh my God.
- and then dip them
- Wow,
- in the guacamole.
- I don't even...
- The guacamole is really spicy,
and that's how I like my guacamole.
- Every bite is a new adventure.
- Everything.
- I need to get a room
with this thing, this is so good.
- Would you like to be alone?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- I can turn.
- (laughs) Excuse me.
- If you go to a party with this,
- you're in!
- Immediately.
- Friendship.
- I never thought about
putting a taco on a pizza,
but now that it's been
done, I never wanna go back.
- Guess who's havin' a
salad for dinner? (laughs)
I probably shouldn't even have dinner now.
- God bless Tony Baloney.
- Thanks, Tony!
I sound like a broken record,
but breakfast, lunch, dinner,
late night snacks,
weddings, bar mitzvahs...
- Oh, this would be the
best bar mitzvah food ever!
(cheerful music)
(swish and creaking)